okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at some designs
for program language version 12.3 which
is
uh imminent and this is we're trying to
wrap up design for certain features
and we're looking here at sound and
vision and i think we've already gotten
the long way through this
so what's next so one thing is
back up a little bit okay go ahead
charlie
yeah under the generation sub section we
would need to go back to the slideshow
video frame table video and frame list
video
okay um those are the three names you
suggested last time
that we we have tentative documentation
for them in there
now um i guess two
two things i want to mention none of us
remember
frame table video or find it easy to
remember
slideshow video i don't have strong
objections to the name or design
however we have deviated from what you
proposed last
last time so maybe look at what is in
image image image one second each
yeah i have no idea whether one second
is the right default time i'm sure that
there are many
slide showing apps that have a default
time we should
see what it is
but again i'm sure for different use
cases there are different defaults i
i don't think for as general purpose as
we are we can find the default that
makes everyone happy okay
so you're preserving the second argument
for something other than the
durations potentially
but then if you recall the second
argument dt was in conflict with the
explicit dts anyways
so um we and and then again for time
series it doesn't make sense it seems
like the
design on the top seems to be at least
more consistent
well you mean you mean mhd and then dt
yes yeah well the time series isn't dt
at time series is t
correct exactly but then time so this
isn't
this wasn't time series yeah i
understand the last case is the case
where you do have absolute times
and it isn't something where if you give
a time in 2025
it's not you're not going to be like
waiting until 2020 it's not gonna it
it's gonna be relative to the beginning
of the time
series right yes it won't weeks until
2025.
uh okay now the thing is that time
series comma dt doesn't make sense
and that's and and right with the
only with the single argument use in all
of the syntaxes
i think this is not going to be
confusing or
no argument is going to be ignored
yeah i think this is okay okay uh
let me think for a second
yeah i mean in terms of documenting this
i would put this usage higher up
okay maybe even
the second usage because i think that's
going to be a really common case
okay
um
okay
frameless video is the full speed here's
a list of frames make this a video is
that correct
correct okay
frame table video is a function
being used to generate a video
right frames of the video yes okay well
i think that's an obscure concept in its
own right
and personally i think this name is for
that concept is a good name
do you have a proposed alternate name
not really i think it's a perfectly good
name for a rather obscure concept
i mean it's a table and it it leverages
the table
story
i think it's a decent name we'll leave
it as experimental if it's still obscure
in a few months then we can rediscuss it
but i think it's a decent name for what
this is
because it isn't it isn't your everyday
concept it's not like a slideshow it's
like a
well you're generating it from
expression and it's just like
by the way i would
um yeah okay fine
i would make it clear that this is a
yeah i guess i guess i mean if it was
expert here i would understand what this
meant
or f explore something i i actually
agree
i we we said last time we'll call it
frame so that's how i documented this
but i actually think expert would make
it a lot more
clear yeah right frame expert
there are two e's yeah that's a little
weird i would call it f
expo or something okay
containing end copies of
the the frame
some i don't know you can figure this
out that is also kind of misleading i'm
not sure it really contained
it doesn't necessarily contain any
copies of frame it could be a state
dependent expression
right right
i agree could have a plus plus on it or
something
yes and might do in certain cases all
right so fix that
all right but this looks good though
okay frameless video we understand right
we do and that's going to be by default
at full frame rate right correct
yeah these are nice functions
quite nice functions i mean this frame
table video will let you do things like
uh you know um well
actually there's one more thing okay
there's one more thing
which maybe needs a name okay
which is the analog of plot for video
right it's frame it's the continuous
thing
it's almost like frame video or
something i don't know what it is
is the okay it is the
it is to table it is
it is the plot alongside a table if you
understand what i'm saying
because what it would be is it would be
frame
i don't know what frame video of a
function
exper t goes from zero to one
where you know that's in time so
it's basically a thing like play
making sense
and so the sampling unlike the frame
table video the sampling is
on us yeah that's correct
and we always interpret those t
as a number of seconds and we
will subtract the starting point
for the to get the timestamps of the
video
yes just like play
i i don't know what play does actually
if you if you start it from one to two
or something let's try it
yeah there shouldn't be any silence at
the beginning
okay well if that's what you think i
mean
this this seems to me useful probably
more useful than frame table video
although they both have uses they both
have uses i mean
frame table video
would be you know particularly and ethan
on the livestream is talking about
parallelization and i agree we need to
talk about that for a second
but let's these all should uh support
saying parallelize of
whatever is in it um
and and so the generation of the frames
is done in parallel
the writing as we've said before needs
to be done sequentially
for which accordingly
well you need to have a very you know
top of the page
example of parallelization then if
you're gonna if you want people to use
parallel eyes
it should be mentioned in the notes and
yeah but the examples are low down we
can move them up
yeah you should move them into the into
basic examples because it's going to
come up all the time
sure i mean there's even an argument
that there should be a parallelization
by default
what do we have we have a bunch of
functions they're parallelized by
default can we
uh i don't think not as much as you
think i mean so low level functions do
like linear algebra and so on no i know
that but there are ones that are top
level
i know in the function repository there
are ones that parallelize by default
yeah we had we turned on we need to
revisit this
we turned on and then some people
objected to it so we need a more
careful use of parallelization because
people objected to us parallelizing as
well
we need to talk about this because this
is this is something which is yeah
we do and it's really one of those that
we have to have lcc or some something
like that because
we we need to sort of get some system
level agreement so
when are you is it okay to start sub
kernels or not
and if so the answer right the answer to
that
should be in the way that the kernel is
started through the front end
you should be picking i mean right now
we have this very impoverished
you know kernel configuration system
in the front end yeah woman is working
on a better version of that
i know in the better version what we
probably should have
is something where it says you know
serial only so to speak
yeah i mean i think we nevertheless we
should bring this up in another meeting
and talk about no i agree
it's a little bit like progress mode
progress reporting and things
it's we kind of need to agree
system-wide
i agree i'm i'm just saying i think the
right place for it i'm just saying it's
going to need people from the front end
here because
oh yeah right because and it's going to
need roman as well
yeah and um uh because you know i think
what's going to happen is
that the default kernel that people
start
is going to they'll be able to pick the
default kernel to start you see what i'm
saying
yeah yeah i
think if we refine this a little bit i
think we're kind of keen to turn it on
in
a bunch of areas that we haven't
traditionally used like symbolic
computation and all kinds of
errors but here's how we should do this
in the toolbar
in the notebook toolbar that hopefully
is coming in 13 um there should be an
indication that says
you know currently running sequentially
or that little little thing that
indicates what kind of kernel you're
running
i think there will be a way to do it you
can set that to allow parallelization or
not
and then there's some fighting chance
that users have of discovering that
feature
that make sense
yeah i think we have to bring that up
you know all right fine so let's get
that but it's
super much more interesting now when
there are many more cores available to
people
absolutely no i mean this is clearly i
mean does it will this run i won't run
for me yet because i'm it's not on my
parallel machines yet
otherwise it's cool because you know i
have 157 cores now
and um so that's a big deal in terms of
making
a video absolutely it's perfect for that
kind of
job it's unbearable right
question um
uh somebody should check that jesse's
uh remote batch
job submit works with this stuff
you see what i'm saying i mean it's
essentially a render farm application
um and we should get some examples of
that and we should get a workflow for
that
you know how to generate a movie of your
whatever
using using this yeah
okay now the thing i'm bringing up here
this frame function video
i don't know whether that's the right
name but it's not the worst name in the
world but that
that's this and the way i see that and
by the way roger i think we finally get
to do
all your dolly moves or whatever the
heck it is yes
um uh what is our plan for that because
this is so protecting it from geometry
uh and actually we actually i take that
back because we've talked about charlie
and i we've talked about
two for video generation here um
uh from 3d yes so we've talked about it
here too for the next
probably a subset of those are coming
into the next
to 13. how will it work it'll be
viewpoint
arrow and then some dolly thing or
something
i don't know yet we haven't talked
design yet okay
however i would like to object to the
whole idea of this frame function video
i think the
benefit of having play versus list play
is that if you look at
input form of that output 25 it's a
sample this
is not not sampled um
oh gosh what is it it's a function thing
i know what it is it is a function
but in the case of the video we are
going to sample the function anyways and
store explicit
frames so really the only thing that
makes
frame function video different from
frame frame table video is
a step and just just for that small
difference you still want a new function
i think so because i think it's
conceptually different for people
i mean
look we have a separate discrete
plot which i don't use very much
um
i mean
yes yes i think they're different things
i mean one it's auto determining and
maybe in the future it will have some
very elaborate scheme
for figuring out oh nothing's changing
at this point it could be an adaptive
you know one could imagine something
where it is an adaptive generation of
frames
making sense but still at the end we
talked about it last time there is no
adaptive frame rate so still
every single frame that gets written
into the files
should be written to the file yeah well
fair enough
i still think conceptually it's useful
to have something where
it's just a function in seconds
so i don't want to bring do the whole
discussion about video generator again
it has
flaws as you pointed out but that was
the whole idea
it's a function of real time i know i
think this one is just like a different
syntax
more or less for figure generator that's
what it is you know
and we've when we factored out if the
frame
you know whoever brought that up on the
on the discussion stream i think that
the person was right
i think it's very detailed control of
frames is a use
right this is very non-detailed control
of it
but video generator is incomprehensible
even though it is the same functionality
this is just packaging because
to me i'll just write this
you know as okay so what will be an
example i mean i'll just write one i
mean i'll write
the kind of thing i would want i would
want
okay so let's see an example here okay
so i would say plot
sign ax see i want manipulate
type syntax right yep um
okay now this is where things get funky
because this is now
i see i see icic
really what i'm going to want and maybe
this is a way of
merging frame table video and frame
function video
maybe what i really want is
um i want that parameter i want the
range of that parameter and then i want
to say how long i want it to take
you see what i'm saying that's
basically the functionality i really
want if i say frame table video
and then i give a frame rate or i give a
duration
i'd be a happy person which you can
you can currently say 0 comma 10 with
whatever
step and then the frame rate could be
specified well you see but the trouble
is there are other cases
this isn't right because the other case
is you're dollying around and you've got
an angle and you want to be able to
decide based on the frame rate what
sampling and the angle to use
right but in this case a frame table
video i think this will be useful
to be able to give the duration because
i i'm more inclined to think about
duration than i am
for for you know i would say sort of
mathematical visualizations i'm more
inclined to think about the duration
that i am to think about
the um uh
you know what i'm saying frame rates the
frame rate
yes
now unfortunately that duration syntax
is incompatible with slideshow video
duration syntax
so you'd end up with you know to make it
compatible you'd end up with some weird
thing like this
well the slideshow doesn't even have
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait why would i be
compatible slideshow is a different
thing
i know but i've got an idea
maybe the second argument could be a
duration
no an overall duration
and it could be again if the sum of the
dt
is different then you have to decide you
just have to decide on a priority
okay i don't know probably what happens
is
it will take those dts and fit them into
duration
with the right fractions because i can
absolutely imagine wanting to bank
switch
you know i mean this is the same issue
is it a frame rate here
basically and and if we did that
i see so you're thinking some kind of a
weight
see those dts more like weights yes
or or scales i want to do a slideshow
that's going to last five seconds
okay or i want to do a slideshow where
every slide is on for 10 seconds
okay so hold on this
that's what i would suggest is an
overall duration argument second
and then here we could have a duration
argument
so we go back to this exact same issue
that started this whole discussion
where having the step in the table
specification and the duration at the
same time
they do conflict but here in the frame
table video we don't
yes we do have a step specification yes
that's the whole point of the frame
table video
to fit the step specification i know
that's right so there's a step
specification
and then
we're either saying this is a full frame
rate
or the thing has a certain duration
right so we've got a hierarchy
if you give a frame rate if you don't
give a duration
the duration is automatic it falls
through the frame rate
okay if you do give a duration then
that's the duration you're giving
so we compute the frame rate based on
that or do we drops
frames i would compute the frame rate
based on that
okay i mean it may be we might not have
support for an
arbitrary frame rate
drop frames or whatever it doesn't
matter i mean that this is the
i mean but then you also need
i think to be consistent the thing to do
is to have a frame table video and a
frame function video
where the only difference is that this
is now sampled as a continuous function
for this duration total
and if you omit the duration but then
the 0 to 10 becomes kind of irrelevant
because the
duration will we said it's not
irrelevant it's not at all irrelevant
it determines what the actual values to
be fed in here
are that's the mistake you make with
video generator right that that's
completely obscure right um
the thing that i'm i'm thinking about is
this a typical thing here will be
i want this to dolly around from zero
to 60 degrees okay that's what i'm
thinking about
i'm not thinking about how to put it
into integers and this and that and the
other
so we don't treat that argument as a
real time as you were saying before
yeah that's correct okay in that case
that is exactly what virginia
was doing that's fine that was now i
guess the one question is that what's
the default duration
because then from zero to 60 degrees we
cannot infer
any duration uh you predictive phone
like manipulates um autoplay or
like five seconds fine default to five
seconds
right i think one second is typically
too short ib5 is right i agree with you
five is about right
carlo i also think there's another thing
here which you could do
which is in the animation stuff
let's see how does animate work
by the way what was the last concept of
an animation video
what was an animation video
wasn't that this
remember animation video we talked about
last time
do you remember do we need to go back
and watch that live stream again
maybe you should go watch it again no i
think what we discussed for animation
video was exactly what
we ended up renaming to video to frame
table video
expression variable start and step is
what i have in my notes
okay well there may be animation because
this
animate right that's the exact analog of
this
do you see what i'm saying
so then instead of calling it frame
function video which i don't like very
much anyway
we call it animation video and this will
be the direct analog however
long animate by default takes
default duration five seconds we could
use exact same mechanism
and the option yeah exactly yep
and we can also do
some of these things as well in
particular the one that i was interested
in
um
excuse me this one animation direction
right because i think that will be
useful again for this
for a video can we specify that the
video should loop
do you understand what i'm saying no i
don't think i don't think it's kind of a
file
but i think the direction we can say we
want it to be forward backward or
um how do we say eventually
is there a codec i mean is that a codec
dependent thing whether we can say
uh you know loop the video no that's a
player specification some players allow
for
looping okay okay
well so then we should
i mean yeah we should determine that
i like this animation video i do i think
it goes right along with animate
it's easy to explain to people animators
something that is just
in a notebook animation video is really
making an actual video
so that's frame that's instead of frame
function video
that is correct okay and then the syntax
will be identical
so for example here it could vary in
steps to you which
is stepping on the toes of frame table
video a bit
i mean it's considered we don't need
frame table video it's consumable that
frame table video like
like um manipulate
could just have a du here
yeah these are becoming really identical
i
really think one should be enough yeah
so maybe it's just animation video
if you want it to be non-continuous then
just like manipulate you give it a
step parameter yeah
and then by default five seconds just
like it is for animate
and we're good all right so all you have
to do is rename frame table video to
animation video
and change some things around in it and
give it that duration argument
yeah i think if an animation direction
makes sense i
i don't think any of the other options
okay
all right let us move on yep
this is good we made good progress on it
i really like the animation video name
i think it's easy to understand i agree
okay let's keep going here so now we
solved the original problem that you
were bringing up which is that nobody
could remember frame table video
yeah okay
what's next oh there's some comments on
the live stream let's take a look at
these
uh a comment about remote batch jobs
submitters unusable that's unfair
i've used it quite a bit most people
don't want to
pay for the requested aws frameworks etc
etc etc well
it is for people who do you know
actually
the whole point is you can also use
charity engine which is significantly
cheaper which we've just been using
actually i need to check on what's
happened with that
um it's been grinding away on some
computations for us
uh
um okay ethan is saying what's most
important is that roma makes
remote ssh kernels accessible from local
from the local front end
i think this is the wrong meeting to
discuss that but we can bring that when
we discuss that
i believe that's being worked on but i
can't tell you the precise status
uh accessible to functions with target
device are a gpu
okay okay it's pointing out
export rotating gif which gives an
option for both frame rate and duration
yes but kinji says
very much frame rate resource thinking
have been resolved as defining a
block size variable
don't plan to understand this is the
same as the block
uh to make an fft in real time
okay comments about this would all be
nice the uh
not has used export table of function
yes
this is much better and it generates an
actual highly efficient video
it's all good it's it's the right way to
do this
um but people will end up wanting render
farms
and that's uh it's a good use case for
it really is a good use case
despite what ethan is saying it really
is a good use case for remote patch jobs
submit
i mean yes it costs money but but that's
that's the way it goes
um you know if you want to render you
know you don't get to make a
a a grand movie for nothing
um
of course you could do what i did and
just get a bunch of random extra cores
for you to run yourself because they're
actually not that expensive these days
um okay let's keep going uh
we should continue from bitrate
still in the video section yes okay
so did we finish with bitrate or were we
still talking about bitrate
you didn't like the name uh and i've
been thinking and
talking with people about what else do
we call it
it's it's really bitrate it's really the
number of bits per second used in the
video for different tracks
and what do we call the frame rate frame
rate
and sample rate for audio
and why is sample rate not bitrate
there are two different things what does
bit mean
in this case it literally means a bit
samples so different quantizations for
audio
you know you can have you know
differently many bits
per sample so the unit here is bits per
second
and it's the rate at which like if if my
monitor
is getting data from the frame buffer in
my computer
there's a bit rate at which it gets that
data is that what you're saying
it's then it's not really for this
display it's how many bits are stored in
the file
per second for that video
what it's more transmission it's you
know when you transmit it
uh how how much information i mean
your monitor uses the same thing but
it's chunkier i mean sorry your display
is using the same thing but they
they so you're saying if i were
downloading this as a piece of streaming
video
how many bits have to come through my
yes
the fiber optics yes per second
of video watched yes
and is that right i'm guessing that's
most of the time the uncompressed data
that comes down
because the decoding happens on the
server side when you're
watching a stream this is really how
many bits are stored in the file
and it's more aligned with compression
of the file different codecs different
containers can use
you can use higher compression which
means
smaller number of bits per second and
lower quality
you know it's kind of interesting i'm
looking at this um
uh just on the web bitrate spelled with
a as a single word which looks like
[Music]
bitrate
bps do we have all these units in
waltham alpha
i think so okay
[Music]
um
i don't know if anybody would even
understand it if we wrote
video by trait
so stupid looking but it's one of those
things where it will become an english
word if it's used
much more um
what other than a video could have a bit
rate here
oh i see where you go yeah it could be
called video bit rate instead of bitrate
but the the only problem i see with that
is that
as i said already for a single video
file you have a different bit rate for
audio content and video content stored
in the file
okay so although it's a i really think
bitrate
how do you specify the audio in the
video separately if you go back to the
documentation of bitrate
as a list or association is what we
propose
this is just not right i'm sorry bitrate
is a more generic concept than this
thing that has just all these details in
it
we can move this to a video transcode
and
formats and keep this as a more generic
thing
i agree that bitrate could be used for i
don't know
all kinds of stuff all kinds of stuff
look i think this should be called video
bitrate and if you want to specify the
audio
separately use the syntax and people
know that videos can contain audio
see what i'm saying i can go with that
but but i really think at the same time
the same concept of bitrate being used
for say
i don't know url downloading and things
like that could use the same option
rather than having this have you talked
to those people because i don't know
no i haven't okay so i'm pretty sure
it's a it's measured in bytes
i mean it's complicated there because
we've got to decide on
i don't know how well they know it blah
blah blah
you know throttling i agree that
throttling could use this
although i think it will use bytes per
second more naturally but
it's complicated i suggest that we name
this option video bitrate we understand
what it is here
and if it turns out it gets reused in a
bunch of places we we worry about that
then
okay okay but i think it's worth
bringing up with the
team that um
um
what am i saying it's worth um
i guess with the url download people and
other people
there may be all kinds of crazy bit
right cases where this is useful like
uh you know uploading to an arduino with
through a microcontroller
programmer those kinds of things there
may be some bit right there
in fact i vaguely remember there is a
bit right there i wonder what it's
called
hmm we should look that up
yeah anyway so i mean there's there's
all kinds of random things i think
i think it's it's why don't we try to
inventory where this might be used and
then we can um
ah let's see
i'm pretty sure this sounds a bit right
why this details okay can somebody
report this bug the details here are not
um aren't being don't have a thumbnail
scott can you do that
um ah
baud rate okay
well that's nice and modern i haven't
heard the word bored in a long time
at least spelled that way
that's been out of out of fashion for
like 25 years hasn't it
um okay
comments from uh
i can't i can't parse these names rod
i'll say
what are your bit rate how much info are
you generating per second sample rate is
the size of a chunk you get
every time like a block on a hard drive
a frame rate is just how many images per
second you get well yeah right
i mean a frame is a very big version of
a sample in audio
um analog of that rather
but kenji is saying if you add levels of
abstraction to codec management you lose
real-time data processing flexibility
yeah i don't think um we are
well i don't yeah i agree anyway
okay so look can we please inventory
where else in the system we have bit
rates
and then try and come up with a unified
treatment of that sure
okay what's next
okay what does this do oh this is
deciding how to
so this is for a video player
no no this is for um things like video
join where you're
joining two videos with different aspect
ratio
or other combinations like insert
replace
so i thought we had to conform images
type thing don't we we do
we do yes
so for image assemble
we do not have a similar kind of concept
to this we
we do we do have a fitting argument
which
if you had such an option it could have
been an option
okay wait a minute so the footing
argument for image assemble
does it do the same kind of thing yes
i'm saying
i i don't think we have leather boxing
pillar boxing for assembling
those didn't make sense but filling or
fitting
are available
going on here am i totally confused
something is very wrong with the search
what is that
image assemble could not be found
okay bug bug bug guys yeah please report
okay let me go back
what's going on here what happened to
image assemble
oh i got my own screen amateur
okay
i see fill fit stretch
so here you also have fill fit
stretch as well as others yes
okay and that one it's the second
argument so video join
oh okay
so because it thinks it's a joy and it's
verox
i bet that's a mistake we also support
the list
both both syntaxes are supported
whichever one you think we should
continue it's the same as string join
and all you join
because i mean an obvious possibility
would be to have the frame fitting
it's a pity that we can't use an option
but charlie this should also be an
option to video transcode right
there are more yes video insert video
replace video transcode a lot of other
functions are going to need this as well
yeah we really this is typically where
it comes up
you watch a movie on a television
and it doesn't fit and they have to pick
one of these
sure i'm aware but i mean presumably
this is also something
that when i mean i don't know whether
the whether the
video files allow you to say
if the thing is the wrong shape do this
to it
no not video files again that's a
property of a player
okay well then but for our player then
we'll have to specify this
yes
okay
well frame fitting
what let's look at image conform for a
second
what's i see so that has pillar box
letterbox
yes
so the point here so conform images
isn't there some stuff in machine
learning for conforming images for the
in the uh image encoders
i think there are separate parameters
there you can have
color space option or the image size as
the main parameter and so forth
right now my question is is there an
option that's given
to conform images effectively in machine
learning
that is different from what we're doing
here
encoder just they just get stretched
there is no option for the user to
control that
so in principle there could be a frame
fitting type
option there as well yes
um
okay
um but so
would that would this name frame fitting
work for that case
i think so it's basically well maybe the
other one image conformation the
alternative names we propose
image conformation or frame conformation
i think something with image
may may work better in that scenario
but we're calling all these things
frames of videos
you know i think it's okay frame fitting
seems okay to me
okay
i don't know whether you want the syntax
of a video join with a list of videos
and then the fitting as a second
argument
probably not because it's actually an
obscure case because most of the time
the video
will be taken like with the same camera
or something
i think so too okay
all right what's next here
i think we talked about the video map
family they can take multiple videos
so the much requested assembly of
multiple
videos or compose one on the bottom
right corner of the other one and things
like that
all of those operations are going to
become available
in video map where you can just say
compose the function could be compose a
video onto a video
yes how does it know how to align them
the function should specify that
so if i have a a one minute video
and i am uh i've got a 10 minute video
i don't quite understand i mean i want
to show you time alignment sorry
i thought you were talking about spatial
alignment
yes the time alignment i would i would
say it's from the beginning
and um i don't know what's the ongoing
current implementation we can decide
whether we want to
get the intersection of the videos or
the
union and then whenever we some video
ends
the function also stops
okay all right let's keep going here i
would like to see if we can finish this
more or less on time here
um ali on live stream is uh
uh saying that in version 12 2
replace pixel value is broken
i know we had a few fixes i don't think
they were packed
updated unless they made it i don't
remember anymore
if we had a 12 to 1 or something but
they are fixed
they are either fixed in those releases
or
now in the nightly builds so we'll be
out in 12 3.
okay that's mine for the audio of things
bug fixes and quality improvements okay
do i need to look at these
no not really it was a huge update there
okay this is a big thing right yes okay
let's have a quick look but i don't
think we're gonna wrap in this meeting
and this was supposed to be discussed in
another meeting as well with you i don't
know
i don't think it has happened okay
so we can do this yes
cool so the default is bounding box and
class
so the default will be for images but
later on we expect to do this for text
and other things right
that's really cool um
why does it return the result oh i see a
list of associations region arrow
bounding box
so obviously you should be able to feed
those creatures
in in here right
um without yeah
yeah instead of b box arrow class i yeah
let's figure it out yeah put those
things back in
and probably it should either ignore
that well i don't think maybe it can
even use the confidence levels
yeah i was thinking about the same thing
it could for now
ignore it and eventually use it right
some method
that's nice the built-in detector
functions include
currently we have the first two
implemented faces and image text but
obviously more of those could be there
yes
boy that comes all the way back to my
original design idea
for image you know for object
recognition before machine learning
this was from like 2010 or something
before anybody knew that deep learning
was going to work for these things
i had imagined that we would simply
actually when was the
fukushima nuclear reactor thing what's
that
i have to remember try and get my
because we did this project related to
that
okay 2011. okay so right after that we
did this project for a
client um
the consultant group did a project
analyzing
road traffic flow around that so that
must have been 2011 and we built a bunch
of
you might remember this strategy we
built a bunch of custom car detectors
and road detectors and all those kinds
of things yep
and that was kind of on the tail end of
my idea that we would basically just
curate
200 kinds of objects that we could
detect like you know in a building
windows and this and that and the other
trees and satellite photographs those
kinds of things yes
and um that we would basically
uh you know get just as we've done for
cars and roads that we would get
essentially hacky traditional image
processing well
that was in the in the period when you
know what was it viola jones or
something was the most popular way of
detecting faces
right where it was a just an image
processing hack
and it didn't have anything to do with
uh you know it wasn't
trained from examples very interesting
so we could do that again
now with probably probably with the best
results coming from training from
examples
yes that's really interesting we should
figure out what we think the most
interesting objects to try to detect are
i think roads are pretty interesting
from satellite photographs i think
bodies of water are useful i think um
uh for microscopy all kinds of cell
boundaries are useful
all sorts of things like this huh
oh these old designs never disappear it
was a good design
it's just okay fine
all right of course the real irony might
be if the best
ways of doing this end up being hacky
image processing or if we end up with a
machine learning thing
where we can essentially compile it to
hacky image processing
um that would be an interesting turn of
events
okay well that's really cool uh
speed up rasterize terrific
yeah i mean image cases and so on um
no design change if we get to it there
is
a better back end a better network to
detect object generic option
objects right but i mean so coming is
the hierarchical entity framework
which will affect how image cases
returns its results
okay great
label matrices i kind of want to look at
that you did last time
okay now color conversion was another
request of yours so you can now say
um hue of red you get the hsb
representation of that color
that seems obvious but you know a good
thing
okay
it displays the same but if you hover
over it you should see
hue of different values
that's nice
right okay
okay
video a bit right yes
boy people still care about spss i
thought it was
ingested inside ibm and and
was now does it really exist
maybe people just use this format yeah
now
i think people still use the tool as
well but i guess what
what we care about most is that people
can import their data
okay we haven't had that before yep
we've had we've had various kinds of
bridge formats but i guess that's a
native format
right okay
this code inspections element
undocumented code formatting option
in export this code inspection thing i'm
not sure that's right
you know what i'm saying that that's
returning all the stuff from brenton
yes did that really get reviewed in
in his meeting because i i remember
talking about this and i wasn't sure
that was right
i'm not sure i haven't been involved but
i know this is exactly that
um well can we can we push that back a
bit and make sure that that was actually
reviewed there
sure this was approved that so be it if
not
um let's uh
um
okay uh okay
anything else here
not really good lots of terrific stuff
well done and we finished on time uh ali
by the way is commenting that there are
in 12 2 the second example in the
application section replace pixel value
is still broken
okay yeah i i that i recall correctly i
think we missed
the release of twelve to one uh by a few
days but it is fixed now
okay purkinje is asking about h.264
it is support that i thought it was
supported it's a pretty
standard codec yep well it requires a
installation of full version of ffmpeg
to be used by our system
but yes which means what no actually it
doesn't h.264 is
we're using operating system to decode
and encode that
okay all right well good stuff okay
until we continued um very good thanks
okay thank you thanks folks on
livestream